biggest observation as a kid growing up
in the entertainment industry watching
your two parents work in it
what did you take away from it all i
learned i learned that i wanted to do it
for one
um and for two i learned story structure
from my dad
i mean learning about writing i would
sit down and and watch him
write sometimes and we'd talk about
movies
i learned a bunch from my mom my mom
used to direct me in school plays
so i learned i learned from that which
was great
and how she would talk to children that
were actors but she showed them respect
so i i learned a lot from that
and i i learned a lot from
i visited i visited my dad's set
when i was little uh he was doing a uh
a tv show called captain simeon in the
space monkeys it was a cartoon he was
the head writer executive producer and
um he was also uh directing voice talent
for the show
and so i i go to the the recording
because
he i was three years old and he was
writing the show and malcolm mcdowell
played this character called rhesus 2 on
the show
and i go dad whatever happened to rhesus
one
you should do an episode on that well
sure enough my dad was trying to come up
with an idea for an episode
and he's like that's perfect so they
make an episode about it so they hired
david warner
to play rhesus one and so uh my dad
takes me to the
uh uh the recording studio
uh for the taping because he's like well
you know my son came up with it he's
gonna come to the recording studio so i
come up
and i go up to david warner and i'm
three years old i'm like yay hi
and i go i created you and um
he didn't really find it funny but uh my
dad at that moment
was like you know this this kid has
moxie he's gonna he's gonna do something
and so um i always
you know grew up just thinking i was
gonna be a filmmaker
um and maybe it's because of that
creative environment i grew up in
and maybe it's because of the
experiences i had watching movies with
my dad growing up when he was
when he felt sick um thankfully he got
better but
also maybe it's just something that
you're born with i don't know
but i i know that there's a lot of
a lot of things that surround us that
cause things and
maybe maybe i'm i'm a product of my
environment or maybe
my environment is a product of me